bom há um tempo atrás
tenho visto esse m circulando pela
internet é uma foto a da extração de
petróleo a nas areias betuminosas de
alberta no canadá ea frase se isso é bom
para a economia
[ __ ] economia possivelmente vendo
essa imagem vocês num primeiro momento
tenham até concordado é verdade [ __ ]
economia a mais talvez imediatamente
após alguma reflexão vocês tenham visto
nessa imagem
tudo aquilo que a gente normalmente
tende a reconhecer como sendo os
problemas do discurso ambiental é que
seria um discurso sentimental que ele
apela para essas imagens à de choque
explora uma relação afetiva muito mais
que uma delas uma reação à racional uma
certa ingenuidade não é um pensamento um
pouco imaturo porque ele é incapaz de
lidar com a realidade das coisas e por
último uma incapacidade de compreender o
todo
porque afinal de contas a gente não
poderia simplesmente dizer
dane se a economia nós precisamos a da
economia ea gente portanto vai precisar
desse tipo de coisa e parece que é
normalmente dessa maneira que as
questões ambientais quando elas aparecem
no debate público são desqualificados a
de primeira mão
antes a das pessoas começarem dela telas
a sério essas questões já já são a
desvalorizada são menosprezados por
conta desses preconceitos
a associação delas ao sem
sentimentalismo a ingênua ingenuidade a
parcialidade por oposição aquilo que
seria a racionalidade a maturidade ea
universalidade da racionalidade
econômica
a racionalidade que entende que você não
pode fazer um homem
at sem quebrar ovos o que entende né
aquela conhecida aquele conhecido
aforismo que resumiria a racionalidade
econômica que entende que é impossível a
o que não existe almoço grátis
a tudo isso significa então que antes de
ser de batidas de serem debatidas as
questões ambientais já de saída são
tratadas como demandas e reais ou e
realistas
será que é assim mesmo
é isso que eu gostaria de discutir aqui
com vocês a em primeiro lugar nós temos
hoje o consenso esmagador da comunidade
científica internacional usando os
métodos mais racionais
a comunidade científica a conhece de que
o aquecimento global é uma realidade
a origem antrópica do aquecimento global
é uma realidade ele é causado pelo homem
e que portanto coisas como isso que a
gente vê aqui na foto é a extração de
petróleo precisam acabar o petróleo tem
que ficar na terra não existe mais
capacidade na atmosfera terrestre para o
o o carbono que está armazenado nessa
petróleo e que vai ser queimado a partir
do momento que ele seja a
disponibilizado para o consumo
mais importante que isso porém é a gente
se perguntar o que é mais universal é
óbvio que o realismo da racionalidade
econômica é relativo a uma realidade com
essa realidade é economia
a produção circulação e consumo de bens
por humanos
de onde vêm esses bens de onde vem a
energia que produz esses bens e que
assegura a circulação deles é evidente
que a economia é uma realidade relativa
particular em relação a uma realidade
mais ampla mais universal que é o
sistema físico
e é justamente que está toda a questão
diante da evidência científica que não
estamos hoje ser realista em relação à
economia sem antes ser realista em
relação ao meio ambiente é como dizer
que nós podemos almoçar os recursos
naturais sem jamais pagar a fatura desse
almoço é como complementar a crença de
que a não se pode fazer um omelete sem
quebrar ovos com a fé numa galinha dos
ovos de ouro que vai seguir nos dando
ovos para sempre uma primeira resposta
que a racionalidade econômica poderia
ter diante disso seria tudo bem
o aquecimento global existe ele é uma
falha de mercado
ele pode ser corrigido pelo mercado
nós precisamos confiar na capacidade do
mercado de corrigir esse problema que o
próprio mercado que o qual o problema
disso é que isso supõe que o objetivo do
mercado seja produzir o bem comum
ou seja nesse caso defender o meio
ambiente ora não é isso que leva os
agentes econômicos ao mercado que leva
os agentes econômicos o mercado é a
busca do lucro tragédias ambientais como
aquelas acidentais por exemplo mariana
em minas gerais ou aquelas feitas de
caso pensado como belo monte
elas não acontecem por engano
elas acontecem porque elas são um
sucesso do ponto de vista da busca do
lucro por aqueles agentes econômicos a
falar sem dizer que o bem da economia
conhecida e com o bem da sociedade
decorre do fato de que nem a economia
nem a sociedade são uma coisa só a
economia distribui o bem de maneira
sempre mais ou menos desigual a assim
como também distribui os custos da
produção desse bem de maneira desigual
mas existe um último argumento da
racionalidade econômica e e se pareceria
à primeira vista ser definitivo
ora se nós concordamos
que o maior problema que nós temos hoje
num país como o brasil mas também em
todo mundo é um problema da desigualdade
social
não se pode atacar o problema da
desigualdade social sem crescimento
econômico está a criar mais igualdade e
mais justiça social é preciso crescer
logo é preciso coisas como essa que a
gente vê nesse mesmo à primeira vista
isso pode parecer um argumento realista
claro se a gente esquece o fato de que
aquilo que os cientistas todos nos dizem
hoje é que não é mais realista seguir
tirando petróleo do chão por exemplo o
seguiu tirando cartão mas né a questão
se coloca parece que a gente estaria
então aí diante de um dilema
diante de uma escolha ou justiça social
o meio ambiente onde está o problema
nesse argumento obviamente naquilo que o
argumento não diz ao colocar essa
escolha ou justiça social o crescimento
econômico o que esse argumento está
fazendo é blindar uma coisa da qual ele
não está falando que é a riqueza já
existentes
ora seria perfeitamente possível
combater a desigualdade crescendo -
bastaria distribuir a riqueza que já
existe é porque uma parte considerável
da esquerda abandonou a antigas
bandeiras como por exemplo a taxação de
grandes fortunas ou como a taxação
pesada das heranças que ela precisa hoje
se comprometer com o crescimento
econômico limitado para poder manter o
seu compromisso com o combate à
desigualdade com a justiça social é isso
que leva essa esquerda
portanto a flertar em o negacionismo
climático
eu acho que a partir desse argumento a
gente pode dizer que o as questões
tyson que a preocupação ambiental como
um todo não só não seria contrária à
luta contra a desigualdade mas ela pode
nos oferecer uma máxima para ação para
ação por justiça social que é diante da
crise ambiental que nós vivemos
acorda tem que arrebentar do lado mais
forte é o custo a da transição para uma
economia com outra base energética é um
rosto que necessariamente tem que ser
marcada por quem lucrou mais com a base
energética que nós temos hoje
se é impossível seguir crescendo de modo
desenfreado e se nós não queremos
abandonar o propósito o princípio da
justiça social é necessário então
dissociar a ideia de justiça social da
idéia de crescimento econômico não pode
apenas dizer que todos nós precisamos
fazer sacrifícios quando tanto os lucros
quanto os prejuízos
nessa curva histórica que nos trouxe a
crise ambiental sempre foram
desigualmente distribuídos
portanto pra concluir o que a gente tem
aí é me parece a demonstração de que a
preocupação a ambiental que a luta
contra o aquecimento global e tudo que
segue disso por exemplo contra a
indústria do petróleo não apenas um
elitista qual é mais realista que
acreditar nas soluções de mercado que
aliás são as mesmas soluções que foram
tentadas
já nas últimas três décadas e deram os
resultados que nós estamos vendo ou seja
nenhum
é verdade que a gente entende ecológico
como sinônimo de complexo ou sistêmico
muitas vezes o que a gente viu do
ativismo ambiental não era nada disso
talvez fosse exatamente o contrário não
é uma prática que pensava ambiente e
humanidade como
assim externas um ao outro que se
concentrava nos efeitos e não nas causas
e que acabava sendo assim também
frequentemente elitista satisfeita a os
conchavos de gabinete e as medidas
superficiais de mercado mas me parece
que a partir desse argumento que eu
coloquei pra vocês aqui hoje a gente
pode pensar uma outra possibilidade
nós temos a oportunidade certamente
temos a necessidade de superar esse
antigo ambientalismo cosmético quase
exclusivamente de classe média e pensar
num outro ambientalismo a partir das
populações que sofrem mais diretamente o
efeito de processos como esse em aberta
como belo monte com mariana aqui no
brasil
na direção de um projeto que constituam
uma base social ampla para a qual a
justiça social e justiça ambiental sejam
indissociáveis
isso é possível é difícil saber mas
talvez um dia no futuro a gente olha
para trás e se dê conta que essa era a
única alternativa realista
obrigada marielly por exemplo